anthony look i know you're a prideful
guy man
number one pick in the rising stars game
by team isaiah what does that mean for
you i was number one pick you a number
one thing oh
that's love
nah for sure um yeah that's love it's a
blessing for sure now being in this
experience seeing this
it's cold out here yeah i know you're in
minnesota and so you're a little bit
used to this but what's been your
experience thus far here in cleveland
i've been in the hotel room the whole
time man for sure um but
i mean since i've been here it's been
dope uh all love uh open arms and you
know they're showing good love yeah you
got some um you know this is not your
regular practice attire here is this
because of the cold weather or cold in
here man it's freezing uh we gotta get
some heat on uh get some fans in here
you know
yeah get some heat it's cold in here man
at this point one thing i gotta i gotta
ask you we gotta get to this because
everybody wants to know the answer to
this question and you're one of the most
high-flyness dunkers we have in this
league posterizing guys all the time
when are we or are we ever going to see
you participate in a slam dunk contest
nah man i'm an in-game dunker uh
i don't have dunks like in my bag like
that for like tricks i'm not really a
big trick guy i just like to dunk on
people well you could you can definitely
put somebody in the paint and you can
show this one man it's more like i feel
like the dunk contest is like for tricks
people who can go up there and spin i
can't do all that i'm just i want to
dunk on somebody for sure well and last
last thing real quick man your team
looks pretty stacked how do you think
you guys look in the field right now
i think we got everything we need we got
uh two of the best young three-point
shooters in the league
um we got our great pg here we got uh a
force as a five we got a young guy on
the g league who like you can shoot the
cover off the ball and then you got me
so yeah enough said yeah that'll say it
at the end we appreciate you brother
appreciate it yeah